herzchen wir zu meinem heutigen video
leute heute froh dass wir jetzt reden
kannst mehrheit regieren so kann man ein
paar neue ist ja wie gesagt ich bin froh
hier ist sebastian hinter der kamera ist
die das gerät und ich habe mir wieder
was bestellt für ein video und zwar zwei
dosen was findet diesen dosen tritt sein
fragt ihr euch nicht weil ich weiß ich
habe halt eben auf die dosen drauf
geguckt es okay wir haben einmal ein
hamburger in der dose schnitt einen
döner in der dose und zum glücklichen
ufer wo viele probier freunde menschen
sind die mit mir diese beiden
köstlichkeiten aus der dose probieren
fahrt ja kein bock gehörig und wer die
leute also zubereitung müssen wir diese
beiden gilt für zehn minuten in ein
wasserbad und dafür brauchen wir erstmal
heißes wasser fragt er zurück wir haben
kannst hat den wasserkocher ja es liegt
bitte auslastung ist besser für die ja
für das video auf den fall dass wir
wissenschaftlich ich kann leider ich mit
meiner kamera drehen weil ich drehe
gerade sie mit kaputten auto fokus jetzt
hat das sowas weiter hoffe dass einigen
kinos immer manuell fokussieren also
hier ist wasserkocher los ist jetzt
helfen und was das heißt du musst noch
ansteigen ich hätte würden wir jede
menge wasser rein wenn man das was wir
dann eingeführt hat
schütte 2005 wieder ein ich finde schon
mal topf aus da machen wir es gleich war
lecker lecker erst mal gucken ob es auch
passt
scheiße während nämlich besser
so sei wie schauen wie wir so ist jetzt
fertig ja
münchen hier mal die chance ist denn ihr
was probieren 123 falls nicht die
videoqualität jetzt immens verwendet die
filme hat halb sitzt doch ihr herz
gehört die wahllosen kommt der für zehn
minuten mit kochendem wasser herein und
damit soll angeblich der perfekte töne
aus der dose aber was ist der perfekte
dinner aus der mode
leute das wasser ist gekocht achtung
achtung hatte die vorstandschaft setzt
das einst in hamburger wahl obliegt den
döner aktiv um gerade einfach drauf
schütten wie kann das gut sein und soll
euch bereit man den döner aus der dose
zu wir sehen also zehn minuten
okay wir warten jetzt die minuten so
meine große frage in meinem kopf ist wie
soll das funktionieren soll salat mit
einem brötchen mit dem döner
fleischwaren gemacht werden und das soll
auch nur annähernd wie normaler döner
schmecken wenn du überlegst dass der
salat ist das einzige was nicht
mithalten kann der ist
eine stunde gar nicht dass auch sie
jetzt nachts der wanderer zwei monaten
bringen und ich bin echt sparen für ein
geiler boehner ich fühle mich einfach so
dieses knusprige geil geil alter ist für
mich wenn ich mir eine rolle im nächsten
teil ebenso wie vor viel hatte sebastian
glücklich haben sie der meinung sind
willkommen beim wdr jetzt heißt es
warten ich bin gespannt und wir
probieren alles klar fertig geworden war
dass wir wieder im film verfahren nicht
ich bin gespannt der lakers-trainer hab
erstmal hier diese professionelle
konstruktion auflösen
dann nimmt man eine garantie haben der
spiegel nach greift also drunter holt
die erste dose aus und legt die gehen
wenn jetzt sowas nicht habe dann
schmeckt das nicht einen teller zwei
andere ich da habt ihr ein messer noch
na dann
leute ich konnte es mit dem essen keine
sorge ihr müsst nicht mehr hungrig sein
ja da kommen wir erst mal meine leute
nein ich würde ich als erstes spiel
erste geraten
bayern führt als erstes ist das hier das
hätte noch ein bisschen weiter habe es
selber verbockt haben bürger ist okay
jetzt versuchen dann doch gedacht okay
und renault mit brötchen geisteskranke
ziemlich schneiden
das geht nicht so schwierig abzuschätzen
jetzt macht es geht nicht ab erst mal ab
und fantasie wieder aufgestellt sich
schon wieder den finger fast ein wenig
oder das ist so ist stiegen immerhin
kannst du hast jetzt bewährt aber der
geist aus sieht man dass das sind geile
aus weniger dem st
darf man für das wesen der hat ja echt
ein bisschen knusprigen ist es abend
jurist komme ich auch fest ich habe das
übrigens für galileo nicht dass ihr
denkt ich würde ihm sicher sehr gut wir
haben dir aufmachen oder ich hab es
nicht dass man weiter okay okay ich
wieder kandidieren war auf dem posten
das hier ist der döner aus der dose ist
ein bildungs und dafür bezahlen burger
aus der dose deutsche gut dass sie da
sind ja stimmen haben ist klein doch
eine auswahl der bürger an die konstanz
geht demonstrieren fand ich weiß
hoffentlich haben wir nichts zu tun
leute gucken wirst du sagen keine ahnung
hätte dafür dass das ganze so oder so
droht verhältnis also die haben uns
einladen so was ja getrost weggelassen
genau ich bin eben zusammen aber ein
händler auch ganz natürlich haben
gepasst hat oder die altmärker ich bin
bereit ich sage meinen part mit herrn
oettinger das ist abfall mcdonald's und
so und jede hat er jetzt probieren
schild von all den leuten mit seinem
fahrrad von dem schlag oder tritt
probieren teilweise an findet auch
dieses scheiß verpackung ist man das
standard jahr also andere waren geläutet
gerade essen ekel der mamas die bande
musik und ohne spart und grund kritik
gut verzichten ich finde es nicht
schlimm ich meine foto ernst also die
show dann schaue ich die chance kurz
zweiwöchigen fällt den bürgern boden der
stunde
zwei sind wenn man drauf und irgendwann
wird er am tagesende für den nächsten
tag dann noch als teilchen oder burger
vom vortag verkauft so schmeckt der so
nicht so gut also ich muss ehrlich sagen
du hast deinen post apokalyptischen
szenario wurde nur changieren sammeln
kannst oder zucchini dass das fertighaus
fließen die arbeit aber aber lieber das
war deine battenberger aber dass sorgen
anlass sich zu probieren oder ist ist
das echt nicht meins ernsthaft prof ich
hab dann mal da waren auch als ich sage
ganz ehrlich es ist sogar ein stück auch
ich finde es nicht schlimm aber der
bürger einfach da ich noch mal schaden
sieben tage haft waren da gibt es keinen
döner dazu natürlich geht er also ich
habe auch nichts von dem orden muss
irgendwo aus dem team hat also was aber
auch empfindlich muss ich noch mal der
girls und richtig dass vernünftige und
es schmeckt voll in ordnung oder für aus
der dose oh mein gott es geht sagt das
war schon komisch ist es in ordnung oder
anderen scheinen das zwingt euch zwei
brüder aus seinem ich für so wenig sowie
habe ich habe mir auch dass ich mich
nicht so gut jetzt ist klitschnass
[Applaus]
fertigkeit es ganz vergessen die leute
das richtig gut wie kopfschmerzen hoffe
ich das lieber einen nachteil hier
sollte doch konserviert sein warum ist
das klitschko wasser eingedrungen ist
beim am besten unterstützt für mich ein
schönes und
da ich noch nicht ganz so glücklich den
sound gehört das hat mich schon verkauft
heftiger ich weiß nicht wann sie das
nächste happy ist meine ich nämlich weil
für einen helm bürger aus der dose alter
ich hätte mir nicht mehr erwarten können
aber hier den kreisverband also ich muss
alles durchprobiert dass auf jeden fall
aber ich brauche kriegsdienst mit
lebensmut ihr das nicht ausfliegen sieht
aus wie schweines hinzu das klingt wenn
man denn von unten so anfassen für das
klebt ein pornodreh die bist du da und
nur okay leute aber ich gehe jetzt
vielleicht schmeckt ihr okay ich habe
auch schon ich habe auch schon durian
stillen ins leckerer das lecker und die
meinung von bochum treten
und ich hab dir geräte für youtube leute
abonniert main kiew war aber für mich
nix mit döner zu tun ich bin wieder hier
noch mal dass das dönerfleisch ja das
war schon okay das wird in der ba ist
das ding ist ein fachbüro und in der
dose krautsalat schmid die hose die
zutatenliste steht die aber drauf und
hauptsächlich ist da halt echt essbares
normales erzeugt wird deshalb muss ich
ja was der andere stand
bist du gerade auch geschmack sprechwerk
was mir buttersäure milzbrand bakterien
infektion mit dem bakterium leute mein
fazit ist stoppt wie viel man fast sagen
niemals probiert den döner nicht
probiert ihn gesehen und ich muss sagen
der bürgerweide ordnung denn goethe
sieht für mich aus wegen gekappten
geschissen
das kann man sich absolut sparen
ich danke zu sagen was es geht also
leute auf jeden fall man muss sagen
krass dass man alles in der dose
reinbekommen leute auf jeden fall heftig
dass man es war eine dose reinschnuppern
windkraft das wird vor allem auch von
vielen leuten gekauft die sich halt auch
eventuelle die reise gehen soll die
raten nicht regen weniger
haltbarkeitsdaten auszuarbeiten doch
erstens dass 20 leute kennst du die der
lose gekauft haben mir was wir sind aber
gespart würde
morgen sonntag in köln wurde heftiger
kriegt so der ich will mich vielleicht
für eine person hamburger haus verlosen
heute und läutet das war es besonders
sicher video wir sehen uns nächstes mal
die app lassen auch daumen und hoch